Niazi keys New York became a member of
the European Parliament for Cyprus
earlier this year he's attempting to
break down borders on the divided island
in the Mediterranean Sea we have been to
elected nations as a conflict first time
in 1954 Kiesel Urich grew up in the
occupied Turkish north but lives in the
Greek part in southern Cyprus the
political science professor wants to
fight in the EU Parliament for an end to
the conflict Cyprus has been divided
since the Turkish invasion more than 40
years ago we visit the mayor of potamia
a little village on the Greek side right
at the border the next town is in the
Turkish part it's just five minutes away
but as we're divided by the Green Line
it takes two hours the consequences of
the partition are visible to everyone in
pattaya the side of a missing persons
oh boy them young people missing during
the war this monument was erected just
10 years ago it was a concession to
Greek Cypriot nationalists some see the
Greek flag behind it as a provocation
because potamia is the last ethnically
mixed place on Cyprus it's both Greek
and Turkish Niazi cosy Urich did
especially well here in the last
election because he actively supports a
peaceful solution to the conflict he and
the mayor visited the UN administered
buffer zone separating potamia from the
Turkish north these fields are used by
Greek Cypriots here and by Turkish
Cypriots on the other side the farmers
know each other you can walk from here
already other village over there but
because there is a small danger that
someone can see a soldier and you're
arrested in this case
we're now driving towards the checkpoint
leading into the Turkish north the
border controls take a long time we need
to wait and we're not allowed to film
the Turkish Republic of Northern Cyprus
is only recognized internationally by
Turkey here to national pride is
particularly important to some I am
elected it's a kind of victory of
anti-nationalist Greek and Turkish
Cypriots against nationalism unroot to
Laura Gina there are many heavily armed
Turkish army checkpoints
it's an enclave surrounded by soldiers
Kazu Urich grew up here right outside
the local pub there's a bust of came out
Ataturk the founder of modern Turkey a
visit to mayor Hassan Barbaro's and
supporters shows that many people would
like to see a solution to the conflict
sooner rather than later everywhere else
there's progress but we're stuck here
we need an entry point here to the
cellar Regina was a cosmopolitan village
the islands biggest Turkish village it
was the smallest village on the island
issue on that and an anger cooled five
thousand people are said to have lived
here once today
it's a meager 300 most people left the
village located just at the border to
the Greek South the neighbouring village
of potamia
is so close but inaccessible Kizza Urich
ran for the European Parliament because
he wants that to change in Brussels he's
already testing Cypriot unity we are
sitting here together my assistant I can
Turkish Cypriot Dennis King Sofia
you saw there's also a Greek Cypriot
that we are all together and I think
that is what I want to see in Cyprus
they're setting an example while hoping
that the border dividing Cyprus can
finally be overcome